so when whenever we have a memory about
some experience turns out that they're
probably a lot of different systems in
the brain that are being activated we
sometimes as scientists we sometimes
talk about memory systems but I sort of
think that that's a misnomer because if
you think about what memory is it's it's
really plasticity in the nervous system
it's the ability of neurons in the brain
to change and neurons in every part of
the brain that have ever been looked at
have this capability of changing of
becoming plastic when their experiences
change now from the point of view of a
neuron and experience is the arrival of
neurotransmitter being released by
another neuron so what that does is it
changes the way that neuron responds and
across many such events like that in the
brain a memory is formed are multiple
memories of form so it's really
inappropriate to talk about memory
systems because almost every system in
the brain forms memories so what we like
to think about instead or the way I like
to think about is that memory is a
feature of neurons rather than a
function of brain systems so as
information goes through a brain system
if that information is significant it
will form a lasting trace as a result of
the release of the transmitter and the
other things that are going on at that
same time will form a trace a connection
between the active neurons and that will
stay in the brain in the form of what we
then experience as memory later now
let's take a situation where you're
driving down the road and you have an
accident you hit your head on the
steering wheel and you hit it really
hard and the horn gets stuck on and so
you hear this loud annoying noise while
you're bleeding and pain it's really
awful and terrible and then a few days
later you hear the sound of a horn so
that sound will go to various parts of
your brain simultaneously when it goes
to a part of the brain called the
hippocampus it will remind you of the
the situation that you're in that you
were driving you had an accident that
you were with John and PEG but you won't
know it won't have the emotional impact
unless it also goes to a different part
of the brain called the amygdala which
instead of reminding you of the details
of the event will trigger emotional
responses in your brain and body and the
ones in the body will feed back to the
brain and all of that activity in the
brain will give rise to what we call the
emotion so back to the the fear example
the sound of the horn goes to one part
of the brain the amygdala and gives rise
to the emotional response to the other
part of the brain the hippocampus and
gives rise to the cognitive
representation so we call the
hippocampal memory a memory about the
emotion whereas the amygdala memory
recall the emotional memory itself now
these two things happen simultaneously
the amygdala memory is triggered
unconsciously it don't have to be aware
of the stimulus in order for that to be
triggered hippocampal memory is probably
triggered unconsciously as well but you
become aware of the memory when it's
triggered because of the but that's what
I hippocampal memory does is it creates
a representation in conscious experience
but that conscious representation now is
going to be amplified by the emotional
arousal that's taking place which is
going to create a new emotional memory
or new memory about emotion that's going
to have that kind of emotional stamp on
it so it's the interaction between
cognitive systems and emotion systems in
the brain that create what's called
sometimes flashbulb memories which are
very vivid strong memories of a
particular experience everyone my age
remembers the assassination of John
Kennedy in the six days remember where
we were what we're doing all of those
gory details now it used to be thought
that these flashbulb memories were more
accurate than other memories but new
research by list helps my colleague at
NYU and other researchers who study
humans have shown that these flashbulb
memories are not more accurate they're
just more vivid so the accuracy is is
kind of suspect and one of the
consequences of one of the implications
of that is that memories are constructed
are reconstructed when they're retrieved
and at that point of retrieval the
memory has the opportunity to be changed
and that's one of the main topics we've
been working on lately is how memory has
changed when it's retrieved
so a good example of the chain the way
memory changes during the retrieval
process is a situation where someone
goes to court to testify about a crime
that they witness and on the day of the
crime they you know gay they gave their
summary of what happened to the police
so there's a police record at the time
and then when they go into the court
they talk about something completely
different which it turns out happens to
match well they read about in the
newspaper and so when they read the
newspaper what they did was they updated
their memory about the experience and
then in the future when you retrieve
that memory it's hard to distinguish you
know what actually happened and what
you've incorporated since and through
other kinds of experiences this is now
well-known phenomenon that each time a
memory is taken out the opportunity is
there for it to be changed and normally
this is an updating process and it's a
useful thing do you meet somebody at a
party and inserts a nice guy then you
find out he's an axe murderer or
something like that you have to you know
immediately change your memory of that
person so you've updated it but in the
in the case there are other ways that
memory gets updated as well which is
that um let's go back to the example of
fear conditioning in the rats so we
conditioned a rap to be afraid of the
tone so the next day he hears the tone
and he freezes because that's how rats
expressed their fear of stimulus but if
immediately after presenting that tone
we give the rat a certain kind of drug
which I'll explain later and we test the
rat the next day the memory is no longer
present or at least can't be accessed so
what's going on well it's been known for
a long time that memory formation our
memory consolidation requires the
synthesis of new proteins in the parts
of the brain that are forming the memory
so other researchers discovered then
that memory that if you block protein
synthesis after retrieval you can also
disrupt the stability of the memory
later
but that idea kind of got lost in the
late 60s and didn't stick around what
stuck around was the idea that memories
are consolidated and once they're
consolidated each time you take it out
you take out that same trace over and
over again so the the new research which
my lab to help sort of rejuvenate in the
year 2000 was about manipulating the
memory after the route experiences the
retrieval process so we give the wrap
the tone and then we block protein
synthesis after retrieval rather than
after learning and when we do that again
the memory is eliminated just as well
after retrieval as it is as it's
prevented from a court being required
after learning if you block protein
synthesis so the unique feature of our
experiment was we were able to do this
in the side of the brain where the
memory is being formed and stored which
in the case of fear conditioning memory
is the the amygdala so because we had
done all the the basic work of figuring
out those circuits we could go in and
put a tiny amount of a protein synthesis
inhibitor in the amygdala and that's
important because you can also do this
experiment by giving the protein
synthesis synthesis inhibitor
systemically to the whole body like if
you do if you take a pill that goes into
your body and reaches your brain and
does all the stuff but it's going
everywhere that's why many drugs have
side effects so if you take an
anti-anxiety drug it not only relieves
anxiety but it makes you sleepy might
alter your sex drive blah blah blah so
what we're doing here is avoiding one of
the bad consequences of protein
synthesis inhibitors which is it makes
you nauseous and sick and so forth if
you take it systemically and it is
pretty toxic so you've never give a drug
like that to a human this is only
something you can do in an animal
experiment so the protein synthesis
inhibitor in our study so is put
directly in the amygdala and we avoid
all those side effects and negative
consequences since it's a tiny amount it
doesn't affect the rest of the body so
when we do that through the the rats the
next day don't freeze to the tone
remember that the tone is now dangerous
so this has triggered a whole wave of
research now on the possibility of using
this as a treatment for post-traumatic
stress disorder because you know
theoretically we can have the people
come in remember their trauma give them
a pill and the next time the the cues
about the trauma come long they won't
have the emotional response to it
well when I was a kid I was really
afraid of snakes i grew up in louisiana
where there are tons of really awful
snakes called water moccasins and we
used to go waterskiing all the time in
every waterskiing spot as this legend of
the person who falls in the water and
says i'm trapped in some barbed wire or
something down here when they pull them
out he's covered little tons of baby
water moccasin just sucking away on them
so i was a really good water-skier
because i learned to ski without getting
wet so i would stand up stand on the
pier and the boat would take it off i
just jump in on the skis and ski around
and then just ski back up on the land so
but I the way I acquired this fear of
snakes i think is we went crawfishing
once at this old Bayou and there were it
was a hot afternoon and the Bayou had
remember this very vividly this is my
flashbulb memory who knows if it's
accurate but it's very vivid so it has
the sloping side of the bank of the
bayou and there were like seems
thousands of snakes on both sides its
kind of basking in the Sun and just
formed a really terrifying vivid memory
but I you know I don't really worry
about snakes anymore I today I when I
was younger I would if I turn to a
picture of a snake in a magazine free
camp but it doesn't really bother me